répéter encore et encore inlassablement
un quotidien pour ces jeunes yvelinois
depuis quatre ans il forme le melting
urban coup une compagnie de jeunes
danseurs sélectionnés sur audition
une compagnie récente créée par aurélie
aldebert leur chorégraphe et professeur
de hip hop
car fait par terre et eléonore placera
au pis s'il vous plaît le tout premier
objectif de cette compagnie c'était de
permettre à des jeunes de monter sur
scène et
et de et de montrer ce qu'ils avaient
dans le ventre et ce qu'ils avaient
envie de monter sur scène et de partager
des scènes vraiment avec d'autres
groupes que ce soit des groupes hip hop
mais voir aussi s'ouvrir sur d'autres
styles de danse comme la danse classique
le moderne le jazz le contemporain
dix jeunes de 14 à 17 ans qui ont fait
de la danse un loisir quasi
professionnelle deux à trois
entraînements hebdomadaires et des
stages il jongle leur passion avec leur
quotidien de collégiens et lycéens ont
ces faits là on a des trainings 1h30
technique et trois heures en compagnie
heureusement fin heureusement c'est le
samedi les trainings en compagnie mais
c'est assez compliqué parce que
justement 17 ans en terminale j'ai le
bac et le travail voilà mes origines
nous dit toujours que c'est d'abord
l'école et ensuite la danse je suis
toujours en fait parce que je suis très
compétitive donc faire que du loisir je
pense ça me il manquerait quelque chose
donc travailler beaucoup ça j'aime bien
de base moi la danse est une passion
j'ai envie d'en faire mon métier plus
tard
du coup pour moi ce n'est pas du tout
une contrainte est de pouvoir entrer
dans une compagnie aussi jeune c'était
un rêve de petite fille ce samedi ils
passent un nouveau concours des
rendez-vous qu'il présente une à deux
fois par mois
cette fois ils sont aux scènes urbaines
du nid cypher
on a fait un concours chorégraphique
parce que ça donne un challenge pour les
compagnies mais avant tout c'est le
plaisir de monter sur scène c'est le
plaisir de voilà ont créé une
chorégraphie ont créé un show et on le
présente devant la famille devant les
amis
un petit peu stressé mais
ça va c'est la dernière ligne positif
donc non là c'est on est motivé pour
donner le meilleur de nous mêmes et à
faire kiffer public en fait huit groupes
sont en compétition pour la catégorie
junior les melting urban crous sur les
troisièmes à se présenter sur scène
pour cette deuxième édition il termine
3e prochain objectif la finale de haut
sauf groupe pro le 17 mars prochain avec
dans le viseur le mois de mai les
qualifications du hip hop international
france à orléans pour tenter de partir à
las vegas
[Musique]